We are in a hundred year global pandemic and
our president is dramatically mishandling
it.
So I do want to keep you apprised as to what
he's been up to for the last 72 or so hours.
Donald Trump spent the weekend at Camp David
that a Fox News virtual town hall on Sunday
night.
And then he basically took yesterday off.
If you look at Donald Trump's schedule for
Monday, you find nothing on it.
And yet yesterday was a really big day.
In a sense.
We are fighting Corona virus.
We learned of documents from the CDC.
And FEMA told you about the documents earlier.
They predict that we will spike to 3000 American
deaths a day by June 1st.
Hopefully not true, but certainly something
to be taken very seriously.
We found out states are rapidly running out
of unemployment money.
We found out that states without enough social
distancing are starting to see large spikes
in cases on a percentage basis.
The numbers may still be relatively small,
but percentage wise you are seeing sometimes
the case growth double from one day to the
next.
So we learned last week that even when Trump
does do work, he often is showing up at noon
after watching TV for five to seven hours
a day and sending out outrageous tweets.
Yesterday was a clear schedule, except for
nearly 24 hours of rage, tweeting 6 a.m. to
1:00 a.m.. OK.
I mean, we're talking about 19 hours of tweeting
here all day and night spent tweeting outrageous
attacks and untruth, starting with attacks
on the press.
Bright and early saying, quote, Con cast,
as he calls Comcast, should open up a long
overdue Florida cold case against psycho.
Joe Scarborough.
I know him and crazy Mika.
Well, use them beautifully in the last election,
dumped them nicely, and we'll state on the
record that he is nuts.
Besides bad ratings.
So attack on MSNBC.
Attack on two specific journalists.
Media people Joe Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski.
Three attacks.
It's like 6:30 in the morning.
Then Trump goes directly into talking about
his corona virus ratings and other obsession,
saying, quote, getting great reviews finally
for how well we are handling the pandemic,
especially our strong production of desperately
needed ventilators.
The building of field hospitals and beds.
And soon the great things we are doing on
testing, people are really working well together.
Understand that.
Twelve hundred people died on Sunday.
Another bunch died yesterday.
And Trump is tweeting about reviews, ratings
and getting credit.
This is a very sick person.
This is an acutely unwell individual.
Trump bragging then about something which
actually has been a huge accomplishment forum,
which is one of the main reasons that it's
an emergency to remove him in November, which
is judges.
Donald Trump tweeted yesterday, Republicans
love the biggest tax cuts, rebuilt military
choice for vets, which was an Obama program,
by the way, saving Second Amendment and many
other things my administration has done.
But what they love beyond all else is 252.
So far, federal judges, not including two
great Supreme Court justices, a big record.
Trump is right.
Trump, in in collusion with Mitch McConnell,
have put in place judges, hundreds of judges
who will decide law and cases for your children
and grandchildren.
In some cases, that is how long they are going
to be in power.
He is right about this one and he must be
stopped.
Then Trump attacking California, saying Mexico
is sadly experiencing very big virus problems.
And now California get this, doesn't want
people coming over the southern border.
A classic.
They are so lucky that I am their president.
Border is very tight and the wall is rapidly
being built.
So to date, to this point of the day, he's
attacked MSNBC, Joe Scarborough, Mika Brzezinski
and California, as well as bragging about
ratings.
Then Trump again bragging about testing a
favorite topic.
And if Trump is talking about testing, you
know, he's lying.
He said, quote, By Congress not wanting the
special five minute testing apparatus, they
are saying that they are not essential.
In any event, we have great testing capacity
and have performed 6.5 million tests, which
is more than every country in the world combined.
Remember, we have the receipts.
The United States is currently forty first
in testing per capita globaly.
We're behind Canada, but we're ahead of Belarus.
We have three hundred and thirty one million
people testing six million means.
That after two months of this, we've only
tested 2 percent of the population.
What matters is our testing rate, not the
number of tests.
We are forty first in the world.
Our death rate, on the other hand, is the
14th highest death rate in the world.
Don't take my word for it.
Go look up the numbers.
Then later last night, Trump attacking MSNBC
again, but also CNN tweeting M.S., DNC and
fake news.
CNN are going wild, trying to protect China.
And then this was really late last night.
It was like 1:00 a.m., but it's so insane.
I'm going to count it.
Trump very triggered by a new political ad
against him with a multi tweet rant.
Get a load of this.
Trump saying this is this is rage from a president
in the middle of the night.
It is very acutely unwell.
It's a sign of Trump being ill.
Saying, quote, a group of rhino Republicans
who failed badly 12 years ago, then again
eight years ago, and then got badly beaten
by me.
A political first time or four years ago have
copied no imagination.
The concept of an ad from Ronald Reagan, Morning
in America doing everything possible to get
even for all of their many failures.
You see, these loser types don't care about
252 new federal judges to great Supreme Court
justices, a rebuilt military, a protected
Second Amendment biggest ever tax and regulation
cuts and much more.
I didn't use any of them because they don't
know how to win.
And their so-called Lincoln project is a disgrace
to Honest Abe.
I don't know what Kellyanne did to her deranged
loser of a husband, moonface, but it must
have been really bad.
John Weaver lost big for Casey to me, crazed
Rick Wilson, who's been on this show, lost
for Evan McMuffin McMullan to me, Steve Schmidt
and Reed Galvin lost for John McCain.
Romney's campaign manager lost to Big O and
Jennifer Horn got thrown out of the New Hampshire
Republican Party.
They're all losers.
But Abe Lincoln, Republican, is all smiles.
The UNINTEL it unintelligible rantings of
a lunatic, a triggered lunatic.
So it's a day with nothing scheduled for Donald
Trump after his weekend at Camp David.
Riddled with nonsense on Twitter during which
he attacked MSNBC, CNN, Joe Scarborough.
Mika Brzezinski.
California, some Republicans, Kellyanne Conway's
husband, George Conway.
Republican strategist Rick Wilson.
Steve Schmidt.
Evan McMullen, Mitt Romney's campaign manager
whose name he doesn't know.
And Jennifer Horn, while bragging about his
Corona virus ratings and lying about Corona
virus testing.
This was just Monday.
He also spent the weekend rage tweeting with
all sorts of different claims, including that
journalist Nicolle Wallace was thrown off
of The View, quote, like a dog, like a dog.
That is the president of the United States
thanks to sixty something million Americans.
We must act
in November.